les jours du quartier ici vivent avec le
guet je reçois un coup de téléphone et
si vieille dame qui m'appellent pour me
dire monsieur le pasteur il n'a pas crié
à minuit moi je m'endors tout de suite
après le cri de minuit alors s'ils
crient pas à minuit jusqu'au bas monde
ans
quand la nuit tombe sur lausanne un
curieux rituel se prépare la cathédrale
est soudainement envahie par un étrange
personnage
plus de 600 ans la tradition des gays de
la cathédrale a traversé l'histoire
ça remonte au bas moyen âge on sait pas
exactement quand on a des registres qui
nous disent que au début du xvème
c'était des soldats qui devait se
charger à la fois de la surveillante la
vigilance de la ville pour qu'il n'y ait
pas de départs de feu pour qu'il n'y ait
pas des attaques sournoises puisqu'on
était vraiment au carrefour de plusieurs
routes et c'est ainsi qu'est née la
tradition du guet du verbe gaieté donc
celui qui guette celui qui observe
simon bat un étudiant en langue chinoise
fait partie de ces guetteurs qui se
relaient durant 365 jours après avoir
gravi les 153 marches de la cathédrale
il attend que les dix coups de cloche
annonçant 22h et sonné pour commencer
son travail
c'est quelque chose qui est très proche
pour pour les lausannois et donc c'est
quelque chose qui est toujours présent
pour moi et puis un soir comme vous ce
soir je j'ai décidé d'aller rendre
visite à la personne qui qui était et
qui crient à l'erreur ce soir là j'étais
conquis par ce lieu charmer et je lui ai
dit que si d'aventuré il y avait une
place dans la petite équipe dédaigné
légué suppléants qui se libérait pas je
serais très intéressé
ça m'apporte le un cadre calme au dessus
de 2 comment dire du fourmillement de la
ville et de ses bruits donc ça me donne
ce cadre pour lire pour travailler à des
études par exemple seuls
il a salé disent ils à salé 10
parmi les gays de la cathédrale on
retrouve un animateur radio à au
commissaire de la police de lausanne
un ancien chirurgien et même un
journaliste saluait il a sauvé au pour
s'y montre perpétue la tradition est
vraiment important c'est plutôt dans cet
esprit là que l'on que l'on que l'on ait
une gué de la cathédrale c'est plutôt
observer sa sa ville avec avec
bienveillance et espérer que tout aille
bien que tout aille bien et que voilà de
constater la ville paisible sous ses
yeux
seuls 11 111 perpétue une coutume voilà
donc ce qui anime les gays de la
cathédrale
quand on demande à simon s'il n'a pas
l'impression d'être un passeur de
témoins de l'histoire
la réponse ne se fait pas attendre ça
c'est certain
tout à fait oui oui oui tout à fait
c'est précisément sa part par la
fonction même est telle qu elle a été
conservée sais c'est de s'inscrire dans
une lignée de de le faire le double
l'espace d'un instant et puis espérer
que quelqu'un d'autre le fera pour tous
et guay de la cathédrale
ce ne sont pas les 40 dollars de l'heure
qu'il gagne qui les font sortir l'espace
d'un instant du tumulte de la ville mais
peut-être bien pour être les témoins
du temps qui passe
[Musique]
il au sol 12
il a so
vous faisiez le canada lausanne
[Musique]